hear what you mean I I understand what
you mean like if if that's the lifestyle
that we want we have to kind of be
willing to accept what it comes with but
who says that it has to come with
control and like having to obey someone
I don't like that idea like yes he's
providing this life for me but he's also
providing this life for his kids as well
you know and I'm sure he's not the man
yeah the man that make the money say
that no I'm I'm saying that he is
obviously providing for his family so
some men are actually happy doing that
they actually want their wife to stay at
home and spend time with their kids and
not it's not it's not a bad thing yeah
I'm not hating on anyone for wanting
wanting what they want but but what does
he get in return and those guys
typically want submission in return and
submission is and we have to have a
conversation every time I want to